[Música]
hola me oye
ante bueno hola como están
si estás súper despierta
muy bien tómate tu cafecito de mañana
y encima se toma una taza de café y esta
mañana levante la mano
1 23 24 27 32
perfecto pues adivinen qué esta mañana
ustedes consumieron una droga o una
droga legal ya 2
pues está vigente no claro que no para
nada no yo soy luego las drogas y si no
me conocen yo tengo un videoblog en
youtube en este videoblog me dedico a
hablar de la reducción de riesgos y
daños en el consumo de sustancias
psicoactivas y para eso tenemos que
saber antes que nada que las sustancias
psicoactivas pueden ser legales o
ilegales
por ejemplo la cafeína es una sustancia
psicoactiva legal también el alcohol
también el trabajo pero son sustancias
que a fin de cuentas pueden ser dañinas
si no tenemos una buena relación con
ellos igual pasó con las sustancias
ilegales pero ahora me pregunto si
ustedes se preguntarán por qué estas
ilegales y por qué hay sustancias
ilegales bueno esta pregunta se contesta
con la prohibición cómo surgió la
prohibición de las drogas y hoy les
quiero hablar de
empezando con la prohibición de la
cannabis la cannabis
la marihuana la marihuana ustedes saben
que la marihuana es una planta ligada
intrínsecamente a la cultura mexicana
bueno por la revisión de la marihuana
empezó en eeuu con un rico gordo feroz y
calvo llamado harry potter and singer
o'shea carrick o darling era el
encargado de combatir a los traficantes
de alcohol porque si no lo sabían en
eeuu a inicios del siglo 20 el alcohol
el tabaco religión sigue desplegada en
tomarse de una chevy lo que fuera y
entonces surgieron los grandes hamsters
como el capón y al capone perdón o
bonnie and clyde que lo que hacían era
como algo traficante es algo así como
los narcotraficantes pero del pueblo y
este trofeo los compartía
criminalizándolos
más o menos así era su trabajo a
continuación una representación gráfica
[Música]
voy a dar
ábrelo
ah sí
soy yo
más o menos así era su trabajo pero la
sociedad norteamericana se dio cuenta
que después de 14 años de prohibir el
alcohol no había disminuido el consumo
no para nada de hecho había aumentado y
además el alcohol era más accesible más
bien que consumía y no sólo eso sino que
lo que también aumentó fue el costo de
la policía y del sistema judicial así
que decidieron acabar con esa horrible
política de prohibición y entonces barry
coca liner se quedó sin trabajo y sin
nadie que le firmara sus cheques a
continuación una representación gráfica
de como mi máquina soporte en ese
momento
así todo el ruido se preguntó
ay dios qué voy a hacer ya me quedé sin
chamba como le voy a dar de comer a mis
14 hijos yo creo que tenía
y sale la idea claro voy a criminalizar
otra sustancia una sustancia que sea
fácil de criminalizar porque está
relacionada con arco que la sociedad
estadounidense del tiempo odie no
soporte y se puso a pensar claro que
podría hacer eso que odia menos soporte
quizás era el comunismo no todavía no
papeles acaba de terminar la primera
guerra mundial todavía no es la amenaza
roma y quizás era no ganarse todas las
medallas de oro en las olimpiadas puedes
si les cae muy mal pero bueno pueden
soportarlo quizás será que él no les
permiten llevar sus armas de alto poder
aborda también la orden pero no lo que
más odian los estadounidenses de esa
época se dio cuenta es a los mexicanos o
sí porque era unificarlos pues bueno
siempre ha habido uno deja racista muy
fuerte los mexicanos iván eeuu desde
entonces hacer braceros
voy a tener trabajos temporales para
poder alimentar a la gente acá desde el
lado del río bravo y para poder aportar
es avivar más jornada clarísima de
trabajo sin ningún tipo de comida o
derecho laboral pues fumaba marihuana
entonces se agarró de ahí y dijo que la
marihuana era una hierba dejarlo empezó
una campaña negra o si una campaña negra
en la cual incluso llegó a decir y estoy
citar que la marihuana despertaba el
vínculo de los mexicanos con sus
antepasados los aztecas y que entonces
tenían ganas de sangre y los sacrificios
humanos así
eso es cierto
justamente no los conocemos pocos
mexicanos porque conozco muchos porque
aquí voy trabajo y si por algo en lo que
significamos no es por la marihuana
realmente
por los campos
pero bueno me estoy desviando aunque
esos deliciosos o si el médico incluso
después de que la política de la
prohibición de intentó ser
internacionalizado por eeuu en méxico
incluso hubo un presidente que dijo eso
no tiene ningún sentido no hay ninguna
problema significa de que prohibiera una
sustancia pueda ayudar a reducir su
consumo o acabar con quienes tienen un
consumo problemático decía no este
presidente fue el abuelito de la
democracia lázaro cárdenas
no sólo porque el consumo de marihuana
sino que además esos centros
administrados por la secretaría de salud
en donde ves doctores para consumidores
de marihuana y otras sustancias como ahí
se le proveía de la sustancia de buena
calidad se veía su consumo y se las hizo
asistía para que no fuera tan
problemático en el mejor de los casos el
mejor modo de acabar con los riesgos y
daños es no consumir pero quienes te
consumen puede tener un consumo que sean
menos problemáticos para islas y ellos y
sobre todo para sus familias y
comunidades bueno
así así así eeuu se enojó esa política
de lázaro cárdenas duró poco porque no
sólo era una política para criminalizar
a las y los mexicanos no también se
dieron cuenta que ya combatiendo la
amenaza roja en 1950 y 60 había un gran
modo de hacer que en los ejércitos
locales tuviera el dinero y no sólo eso
fueran independientes de los gobiernos
civiles
controlando el territorio y se dio
cuenta que controlar el territorio se
podía hacer a través de una droga la
silla y el ejército de eeuu empezó a
apoyar con más los armados en manadas de
los ejércitos y les empezó enseñar cómo
sembrar droga para así poder tener a los
campesinos bajo su poder y mediante
vender esa droga tener dinero para
comprar armas que estuvieran fuera del
presupuesto oficial y obviamente fuera
de cualquier control civil de cualquier
peso y contrapeso y poder así hacer
contra guerrillas la cristalización de
esa política llegó a través de la
escuela de las américas o si la escuela
de las américas es una escuela y panamá
en donde el ejército de eeuu entrena a
uno y entrena y durante todo el siglo 20
entrenó montones de policías y de
soldados de toda latinoamérica en
técnicas contra insurgentes en su madre
de tortura
hasta siembra de odio hasta cómo
desaparecer gente es muy triste y no
estoy hablando sin saber hay un gran
caso que sale a la luz durante la
administración de reagan salió el caso
de los irán-contras que así llegan los
irán contras vuelo la contraguerrilla en
nicaragua para combatir a los
sandinistas sembraba coca y es época yo
también te sembraba lo exportaba a
través de un contacto en ir al ese
contacto unidad vendía esa coca y opio y
compraron armas obviamente a productores
de armas estadounidenses claro por qué
negocios en todas partes todas las
partes del negocio para poder combatir a
los gobiernos que no le eran cómodos a
washington
en término real
así
así es que surgió la prohibición de las
drogas y así así es que surgió el vídeo
broma que yo hago viendo todo este
contexto me di cuenta que había de
comunicar de un modo diferente que no
habían criminalizar a las y los
consumidores y me dije a mí mismo lujo
peludo
tiempo de salida de estado y entonces
contacté a mi equipo de humanos a
quienes ahora
a mi asistente pero nos pone mucha
atención por favor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todos
hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
bueno creo que representar así este yo
soy rodrigo les juro que no tengo un
síndrome de desdoblamiento la
personalidad es telefónico y mucho menos
y les quiero hablar más o menos de el
proyecto de lugo cómo surgió el
videoblog de lugo y las drogas bueno
luego para quienes no los ha visto es un
joven que está en youtube consumiendo
sustancias a la cámara y diciéndole al
público no se trata de no consumir se
trata
de consumir buscando reducir los riesgos
que tienes a consumir y los daños
entonces es lo que hace es que se
inyecta lo que sea consume lo que sea
aspira lo que se suma en especial frente
a la cámara y nos preguntábamos por qué
luz
todo sufrió con una organización que se
llamaba espolear el cual era una
organización que se dedicaba a la
reducción de riesgos y daños que hoy ya
no existe y que se acercó a nosotros a
un equipo de cuatro humanos
pedirnos que hiciéramos que esta
filosofía de reducción de riesgos y
daños llegara a un público más amplio y
a un público que si consume porque
existe muchísima comunicación al
respecto pero todo es muy académica y
ellos decían bueno pues tenemos que
llegar a las y los adolescentes a la
gente en los barrios al gentes en las
ciudades y no sólo a la gente en los
congresos
entonces pensamos bueno que podemos
hacer pensamos en él por kirchner porque
él no juzga una opinión es un doctor
no es un adulto uno no es tu papá no es
tu tío que es alguien que en cuanto le
digas oye tengo una duda de esto de esta
marihuana si es bueno no cómo consumirla
o porque me dio mal viaje o por qué no
que te vea no te vaya a juzgar
existía esa gran necesidad de
comunicarlo de una manera bien llamativa
porque como les decía toda la
comunicación es muy académica y estos
son ejemplos de más o menos cuando uno
busca de reducción de retros y daños en
google y buena imagen es lo primero que
aparece es eso que hace los diseñadores
acá sabrán juzgar que eso está bastante
feo y no compite con el nivel de
comunicación que existe de la
prohibición existen grandes ejemplos
como los que vamos a ver de la
prohibición ahora mismo
ahí tenemos a un miembro de la banda
molotov inyectándose algo mientras está
con jesús detrás de sí y luego a su lado
derecho tenemos un cómic estadounidense
que habla de los traficantes y de cómo
la heróica you es border patrol
combate a los sanguinarios mexicanos que
quieren acabar con la juventud
estadounidense estadounidense cuando la
mariguana que ya ha sido legalizada en
varios estados en eeuu quienes cuidan
maquinitas se acordarán todavía que
antes de jugar la aparecida es el recreo
está arriba que decía los ganadores no
usan drogas y eso está muy bien mientras
si vas ganando
[Música]
y en menos de un año méxico que surgió
encontraron una planta de marihuana
grande bastante grande en el anillo
periférico una gran habilidad y entonces
te hicieron obvio mandaron al ejército
vestidos de robocop
para arrancar una planta porque todos
sabemos que las plantas traen cuchillos
y las pistolas si no les para pasar algo
los pobres soldados pero ese es el tipo
de comunicación con el que nos estamos
enfrentando una comunicación que
criminaliza e incluso una planta como si
la planta necesitara
soldados entrenados para ir a arrancar
en un jardinero
[Música]
por supuesto
y por supuesto
[Música]
lo único que viene
bueno
[Música]
soy yo es mi cultura
y los 90
[Aplausos]
tú eres excelente
tú eres sin drogas
como tal colectivo
[Música]
este es el tipo de comunicación a la que
nos enfrentamos comunicación en la que
están implicados ya todos los símbolos
culturales con los que crecimos de línea
y sobre todo mi generación esos eran
todas las caricaturas que yo veía este y
que retratan a las y los consuman
consumidores como este modelo de alguien
que tiembla que no tiene control de sí
mismo que está tirado y que no tiene
ningún futuro
así de fuerte es la propaganda contra
una sustancia que es una sustancia o
unas sustancias que pueden ser
sustancias igual de dañinas y de
peligrosas y de controlables que la
cafeína ante ese problema decidimos
hacer un peluche de troya y decir cómo
desactivamos toda esta comunicación
negativa que se ha hecho bueno si las
drogas se retratan como algo
peligrosísimo luego tiene que ser
completamente inofensivo si las drogas
se retratan este como algo de lenta
luego es bien tranquilo si las drogas
son ilegales luego además de todo es
súper niño no entonces intentar no
hablar desde el prejuicio y el tabú que
ya existe de las sustancias sino desde
una una tabula rasa un pizarrón en
blanco y nos dimos cuenta que había que
hablarle al público porque porque
quienes se enfrentan realmente con los
problemas del consumo de los consumos
problemáticos es el público son ahora si
los consumidores no no en la gran
público
que se cabildea en los congresos sino
cuando alguien en una casa tiene mal
viaje y no sabe por qué es o alguien
cree que se acaba de meter un nacido un
lcd y si le acaban de dar otra cosa que
le va a acelerar el ritmo cardíaco y que
no tiene modo de comprobar qué es lo que
lo que lo que consumió y los efectos que
va a tener esas personas que tienen los
problemas reales bueno esas personas son
los que necesitan las verdaderas
soluciones y son las que necesitan el
conocimiento científico de las
sustancias porque algo importante es no
estamos promoviendo el consumo la mejor
forma de evitar los riesgos y daños es
no consumir y eso siempre lo decimos
pero quienes ya consumen tienen que
conocer las sustancias del pp para saber
que están consumiendo qué efectos puede
tener si pueden consumirlos
cómo va a funcionar
un ejemplo es justamente con el lsd
por ejemplo ustedes sabían que el lsd no
genera ninguna adicción
pies edificio lógica solo psicológica lo
único el principal riesgo de lesiones
para personas que tengan antecedentes
psiquiátricos de problemas psiquiátricos
con su familia por lo tanto antes de
consumir lcd cualquier persona en lugar
de conseguirlo en una fiesta oscura
probar quién sabe qué le dieron debería
de preguntarle a su abuelita si hay
problemas y que aplicación a familia
porque quiere continuar el cds o en su
caso a su doctor
y uno que claro se puede acercar con el
doctor y decirle belga doctor quiero
meterme lcd usted que recomienda el
doctor
y cómo va a reaccionar lo que sea así
porque el doctor la verdad es que no
tiene tampoco información porque hay un
tabú brutal no existe la información de
las drogas que es una sustancia como
cualquier otra como el café y bueno
amigo claro si uno consume el cuadro de
lcd primero y luego preguntar al doctor
puede pasar algo así primero hay que
preguntarle al doctor
y ese tipo de problemas son los que nos
pueden llevar a cambiar la política de
drogas estos son datos los de eeuu no
existen estos datos en mexico pero
probablemente sean muy parecidos en este
puesto se le preguntó a la gente del 1
al 5 que tanto le interesan los
siguientes problemas
problemas que me inventan a mí el 94 por
ciento el público respondió que le
interesan muchísimo y en cambio sólo el
5% respondió que le interesan muchísimo
los problemas que le afectan a su país o
el 11 por ciento a su estado nos dimos
cuenta con lugo que para poder cambiar
la gran política de drogas primero hay
que hablar de los problemas que le
afectan a las y los consumidores y de
ahí puse iremos viendo la gente conforme
vaya aprendiendo más de las sustancias y
de la política que lo rodea y que rodee
estas sustancias pues puede ver cómo
puede hacer que mi consumo nuevamente la
familia como pueden hacer que no afecte
a la comunidad y ágil de cuentas
podemos llegar incluso a los que digan
bueno como me meto a la política de
drogas para que no afecte al país
y nuestro mejor medidor también de
cuentas no son no son los virus o los
likes porque porque tenemos que
comunicarle al consumidor es nuestro
mejor indicador son las preguntas que
nos hace el público y cook son preguntas
que le hacen a un peluche y no le
preguntaría nada a nadie más una experta
incluso ha habido ejemplos de personas
que nos preguntan
si se puede consumir sustancias durante
la lactancia y la respuesta es no así
como no se puede consumir café alcohol y
tabaco tampoco ninguna sustancia
psicoactiva porque puede afectar el
desarrollo del feto este no se han
presentado también oye cómo puedo
identificar si yo estoy tener un
problema de adicción y que la gente se
lo pregunte es brutal
así para nosotros es sólo puro y que se
acerque a nosotros a preguntaros no nos
da muchísimo gusto
e incluso hay gente que nos ha dicho
bueno yo tuve problemas muy graves con
las drogas y esto no conocía que eran de
dónde venían cómo consumirlas
y esas personas al fin de cuentas nos
dicen ustedes si los hubiera conocido
antes de pasar a consumir probablemente
mi problema hubiera sido bastante menos
grave una de esa pregunta es muy bonita
e incluso para saber de el nivel de
desinformación que hay porque sustancias
legales en un vídeo sobre alcohol nos
preguntaron si es cierto que no se puede
morir si comienzan días después de haber
chupado
es el nivel de desinformación que se
maneja con las sustancias y con nuestro
cuerpo y lo único que queremos es que la
gente conozca lo que consumen y conozca
su cuerpo pero nuestra pregunta favorita
es la siguiente
no llegó esa foto y una chica nos
preguntaba y luego mi perro encontró mi
bolsa de cocaína que estaba abajo de la
cama y se achicó todas
quiero
la respuesta de ese correo el
veterinario pero claro ella no lo quería
llevar al veterinario porque el
veterinario la iban a juzgar iban a
decir porque tenías tu cocaína
este tipo de problemas cotidianos son
los problemas cotidianos que tenemos que
resolver y que tenemos que resolver con
la wii que como sociedad tenemos que
darle aire y tenemos que dejar de
criminal criminalizar a las personas
quienes consumen no consumen porque les
encanta necesariamente hay un montón de
sustancias diferentes con un montón de
efectos diferentes que suceden ningún
montón de 7 circunstancias diferentes la
gente que está en situación de calle y
que
con el macro o algo operador de los
inhalantes que se mete mona no hacen eso
porque les guste la resaca y el bajón es
horrible te da frío tú en la cabeza no
sabes dónde estás lo hacen porque es una
sustancia que les hace durante un minuto
sentir que son poderosas ante una
sociedad que les ha dado la espalda
y no sólo eso sino que les quita el
hambre les quita el frío les quitan las
ganas de matar se les da una razón para
vivir quizá la razón no el punto no es
criminalizar los a ellos y decir
malditos consumidores porque están
consumiendo ustedes hacen esta sociedad
lo que es no tenemos que decir bueno
como les dimos la espalda estas personas
que sean obligadas a consumir estas
sustancias
cómo podemos hacer que dejar que dejen
de consumir no estoy viendo la sustancia
es mejorando sus condiciones de vida
entonces es importante cuando pensamos
en drogas meternos en la cabeza de los
usuarios aunque todos somos diferentes
imagínense qué grave es el asunto cuando
jóvenes mexicanas y mexicanos tienen
tantas dudas y tanto miedo que prefieren
preguntarle de su salud a un peluche de
internet
[Música]
[Aplausos]